QQ music has been constantly pursuing breakthroughs
I think this is also the reason why it has been popular in the past ten years.
I am Abao, the head of the Android team platform group.
Every breakthrough in the product is inseparable from the creativity, research and development and platform power
So our team has always been very concerned
Google’s technology development and version updates on Android
And try to let users enjoy the new features of the new system as soon as possible.
This QQ music Android 9 version adaptation
It is led by our group.
I am Shawn.
Is an engineer for Android 9
From the DP1 version of P we started to pay attention
Behavior changes and new features of the new system
And start the adaptation work in the DP2 version.
Support for full screen
And the addition of new features such as the native system notification bar style
Let our users feel the evolution of the platform for the first time.
Especially the latter
From the user who experienced the native system notification bar
We have received a lot of praise
From the developer's point of view
The Android Studio experience has also become better and more powerful.
Such as the Memory Profiler tool
Let's make it easier to analyze memory
Plus features such as JNI layer memory allocation real-time monitoring
Make QQ music's memory optimization work very smooth
Music app usually has a foreground process and background playback process
Want to meet Android 9's requirements for background execution restrictions
Renovation involving these two processes
We combed and classified the data transfer and interface calls between the two processes.
In the end, it not only meets the requirements of background execution restrictions.
And in some extra scenes, it won’t pull up and keep alive.
Can save more than 50% of memory usage in some scenarios
We have always been concerned about new languages ​​like Kotlin.
Currently, the new features in our project are basically written in Kotlin.
This brings a lot of benefits to our development.
For example, the average number of lines of code can be reduced by as much as 25%.
And it can also reduce the abnormality of the null pointer by about 50%.
Presumably, in the future, Kotlin’s share of our projects will grow rapidly.
The direction of Android evolution is a more robust and secure system behavior
Lower power consumption and better user experience
We have witnessed on this way forward.
More powerful toolchain and support for the developer ecosystem
We believe in the open and continuous evolution of Android
QQ concerts continue to give users a more exciting music experience